JOHN: Good morning, Hank!
It's Tuesday.
HANK: Good morning, John!
JOHN: Ohhhh
It's a surprise reunion video.
Who would've guessed it?
HANK: I- I would never- I didn't even know I was here.
JOHN: Alright Hank, I have some questions for you.
First question: How many potatoes did the average Irish person eat per day in 1844?
HANK: Do you want me to guess or know for sure?
JOHN: Yes. I want you to guess.
HANK: I'm gonna say... six.
JOHN: 45.
HANK: Wait, what?
JOHN: The average Irish person in 1844, man, woman, and child, average human
ate nine pounds of potatoes per day.
Hank, can you really grow potatoes on Mars?
HANK: Not the way they did in the movie.
JOHN: Okay.
HANK: But yes!
Other ways.
Do you want me to get into it?
JOHN: A little bit.
HANK: Aright, well, you got some serious problems with Martian soil.
It's got perchlorate in it, which is a big, big issue cause that's toxic to humans and also plants.
JOHN: Kay
HANK: Uh, if you can get that out, if you can get some of the other bad stuff out
and you can put in some good stuff, yeah, you can- you could grow potatoes on Martian soil.
JOHN: Even without an atmosphere.
HANK: Oh, no, you'd have to build a thing around it.
JOHN: You'd have to build an atmosphere.
HANK: Yeah.
JOHN: Hank, did you know that potatoes were responsible for at least 25% of Europe's population growth between 1700 and 1900?
HANK: Noticing a trend here.
JOHN: What's the trend?
HANK: Potatoes seems to be the trend in this question Tuesday video.
JOHN: It's weird, I just got a lot of potato questions. I don't know why.
HANK: I also didn't know that.
Uh, fascinating and I bet there's a CrashCourse video.
JOHN: There is! You can watch the Columbian Exchange Crash Course video currently on Hank's head!
Okay Hank, if you could create anything with potatoes what would it be?
HANK: A man. A fully... a sentient being.
JOHN: Like Mr. Potato head?
They already did that. They already did that, it's in Toy Story.
HANK: I want him... I want him to be a thinking, feeling potato man.
JOHN: Have you not seen Toy Story?
Please name three potatoes.
HANK: Um...
The Russett...
JOHN: Yup.
HANK: The Purple
HANK: The...
Goldie Hawn.
JOHN: That's a good potato name!
If they haven't done that, they should.
HANK: Yeah, they should.
JOHN: They should. Why isn't there a potato named after Goldie Hawn?
She's an American treasure.
Hank, can you rename one of your favorite books by replacing one word with "potato"?
HANK: Red Potato.
The Fault in Our Potatoes.
The Lord of the Potatoes.
JOHN: God, I hate that book.
I mean both the Lord of the Flies and the Lord of the Potatoes.
HANK: Oh, I was talking about The Lord of the Rings!
JOHN: Ohh! I have to teach Lord of the Flies this year in Crash Course Literature
and I just openly revile the book, so it's going to be very challenging.
HANK: That will be very interesting.
JOHN: I'm quite fond of, uhh, Their Eyes Were Watching Potatoes.
This is a good question. Uh. Which of you has a better potato impression?
[A Potatoey silence]
JOHN: You know potatoes have eyes, just like humans.
HANK: Not just like humans.
JOHN: [Giggles]
JOHN: Couple questions not related to potatoes, Hank.
HANK: Aw Pshh fshh faa
JOHN: Sorry to do that for you.
HANK: I'm completely unprepared for this.
JOHN: Uh... What's the opposite of potato?
HANK: That, is a potato question.
JOHN: Henry, do you know what the opposite of potato is?
HENRY: Uh, no.
HANK: The opposite of potato is the vacuum of space.
JOHN: I was going to say that the opposite of potato is a boysenberry.
Actual non-potato related question, Hank: Are you stressed about the presidential race?
HANK: Oh God.
Yes.
JOHN: What is your favorite one direction song?
HENRY: My favorite song is...
JOHN: Yeah.
HENRY: ...fallahallaboom.
JOHN: Henry's favorite song is, uh, fallerallaboom
which is what he calls, uh, Bomfalleralla of the, uh, Swedish hip-hop song on The Fault in our Stars soundtrack.
JOHN: Hank what do you prefer, Potato Pizza, or Pizza Potato?
Hank: Potato Pizza.
JOHN: I also like potato pizza, it's an old favorite of mine.
Under-appreciated Pizza!
HANK: Yeah! Actually, I've had a lot of good potato pizzas.
In the western Montana fair, they have this thing called the 'tater pig'.
A tater pig is just a hollowed out potato with a hot dog shoved in it.
HANK: It's not very good!
JOHN: Alright Hank, thank you for participating in Question Tuesday!
JOHN: Hank, I'll see you on Tuesday. Friday! Whatever.